we at the khan academy take feedback
very seriously we're constantly trying
to improve and we recognize that we are
at the early stages we have a very
imperfect product and and we can only
hopefully improve and that's why we have
we're working with as many teachers as
we can some are are directly part of our
staff we have teaching consultants we're
working with some researchers but i
wanted to make this video because
sometimes the feedback itself can be a
teaching moment and the video in
question is this video which is in our
physics playlist which is essentially a
video about calculating what the
velocity might be for a stationary rock
dropped from a height what the velocity
might be right before
right before it hits the ground
and we just recently got some pretty
high profile feedback from a blog writer
at wired magazine and this is the url
where you might be able to find that is
rhett allen who's a associate professor
of physics at southeastern louisiana
university and i'm i'm i'm confident
that this was
intended as constructive feedback but
the reason why it's a teaching moment is
because it's it's wrong and i'll read a
little excerpt from it right over here
if i had to focus on one main problem it
would be khan's lack of respect for
vectors in particular he set a vector
quantity equal to the scalar value of
zero
and then we come back down the other big
error con makes it say that a velocity
going down would be a negative vector
some other things right over here really
khan is trying to do a one-dimensional
kinematics problem
really concentrating to a
one-dimensional kinematics problem in
this case you don't need to include the
vector idea so the one part of this that
i do agree with is this statement right
over here that we were trying to do a
one-dimensional kinematics problem and
then this situation that one dimension
is the vertical dimension the up down
dimension but in order to kind of
understand why
the second part is very very very very
wrong is to just go back to a definition
of what a vector is so a vector
a vector is something that has a
magnitude
magnitude and
and a
direction if you just had a magnitude
you're talking about a scalar
if you're just talking about a magnitude
you're talking about a scalar so if i
were to tell you that a ball is
traveling at five meters per second i'm
only telling you how fast it's going i'm
only giving you at speed that would be a
scalar expression a scalar value i just
gave you but you wouldn't know whether
that ball is traveling up or down even
though even if you knew that we're
dealing with the one dimensional
situation in order to know whether it's
going up or down i have to specify a
direction so if i were to say so if i
were to say 5 meters per second that's a
scalar if i say 5 meters per second up
or down that is a vector it's not using
the engineering notation that you would
often use once you have
multi-dimensional vectors but this would
be specifying a magnitude and a
direction and in fact when you do
one-dimensional vectors the convention
typically is if you're dealing that one
dimension is in the vertical direction
it's not a it's not a ridiculous
convention when you say well we'll use
the sign of our we'll use the sign as an
indicator of direction so positive could
be up and negative could be down and
even when you're doing precalculus
classes you study parametric equations
you'll often study a particle that's
traveling in one dimension and you use
the convention that positive is to the
right
and negative is to the left and when you
set up this convention and that's what
was done in this video right over here
you are setting these up as vector
quantities they're not done in the
traditional way when you're doing a
two-dimensional vector and you're saying
i j and k but when you set up the
convention that was explicitly done in
this video right over here
your sign is specifying is specifying
the direction and so allowing this to be
a vector expression so this is a a very
wrong statement that in a
one-dimensional kinematics problem you
don't need to include the vector idea
because later on we build on this video
where the the ball actually does switch
directions and if you don't have if you
don't in involve the vector idea there's
no real easy way to express that
switching of directions even in the
one-dimensional case and then once you
have that convention if you set up that
convention in your video or in your
explanation that positive is up
and negative is down it's completely
legitimate to say that the vector the
velocity vector can be zero in our one
dimensional case that means it's
stationary it's neither going up nor
down so i just wanted to clarify that
and i think just the the the critique of
the critique hopefully can be useful for
uh students who are trying to parse all
of this and i really do appreciate the
feedback from from
rhett allen because i think it it
introduced a very important conversation
here